foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight I'll please welcome our sense to
Donald Trump returns to Facebook in a
stunning boost for his campaign to
return to the White House is he a
victory for free speech or for hate
speech we'll debate that with the sense
of social media star who's actually been
advising Trump on his comeback
Jesus was non-binary and Judas was a
woman according to a woke washed
reversioning of Jesus Christ Superstar
his culture caving to the culture
Warriors I'll ask the musical's
legendary original Lyricist to Tim Rice
and staged Legend Tom Conte
thus Austin wanted to Star Brendan
Fraser says we should be more kind to
the morbidly overweight but his body
positivity one of the big reasons for
the Obesity epidemic is fat shaming
actually not a bad thing I'll be joined
by a top TV chef Tom code you lost 12
stone come join me live
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
worship him or detest him and it's
usually one of the two Donald Trump can
never be fully written off hammered by
lawsuits humbled in the midterm
elections hemorrhaging backers to his
younger rival Ron DeSantis Trump still
believes he can return to the White
House and returning to Facebook and
Instagram might be the first big step on
an explosive March back to Power
campaigning used to be about pounding
Pavements bashing phones kissing babies
heads now the heat is where we all spend
hours every day on social media that's
why Trump's banned from Twitter Facebook
and Instagram was seismic the tech giant
suspended Trump the glorifying and in
their view inciting and Insurrection on
January 6 of the capital they choked off
his ability to spend hundreds of
millions of dollars riling and rousing
tens of millions of voters the most
damaging for Trump they choked off his
ability to be the center of attention
this was why they did it
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us from me from
you from our country this was a
fraudulent election but we can't play
into the hands of these people
we have to have peace
so go home we love you you're very
special
well it was a little bit late for that
wasn't it because people had already
started dying at the capital uh and it
was an outrageously irresponsible thing
that Trump did in relation to that event
he whipped up his supporters into a
frenzy in the other steps aligned again
then I'm sure he will be banned again
because Free Speech always comes with
some guard rails you can't incite hatred
demand violence or shout fire in a
crowded theater but Banning Trump is at
the heart of a much bigger debate who
gets to decide what those guard rails
are big tech companies themselves are
unelected and unaccountable so why
should they get to make decisions that
literally change the outcome of
Elections a former leader of the Free
World a man who got 74 million votes in
the last election was banned for
inciting violence but the Ayatollah of
Iran who literally has called for
America to be wiped off the map still
has a Twitter account which he uses to
spew Holocaust denial and demand actual
War the Communist Party of China has
used Twitter to say it's genocide
against a week of Muslims is about
setting them free Putin's Kremlin still
pumps up propaganda even as the Russian
army blows up maternity hospitals in
Ukraine human rights abusing despots in
Venezuela and Saudi Arabia were deemed
acceptable too now billionaire Elon Musk
wants to fix this nonsense he spent 44
billion dollars buying Twitter and he
did that after one of his favorite
satirical websites Babylon B was
suspended this is what they do
what my mom got you an apron this
Sparkle oppression and a shackle of this
heteronormativity I belong in the world
toppling gender stereotypes
objectification inequality and the
subjugation of half the world's
population
[Music]
breaking news World War III has
officially commenced as our mission goes
to war the president has declared that
one able-bodied member of each American
household will be drafted into the
military on the other hand traditional
gender roles exist for a reason I'm your
wife and I belong in the kitchen
well you may not share any of my sense
of humor although actually I do Babylon
B which is a funny conservative
satirical site was actually banned for
posting that a trans woman in the US
government Rachel Levine was one of
their men of the year you might not find
that funny you might even find it
offensive that's your right but is it
really more offensive than the Ayatollah
of Iran tweeting that Israel should be
incinerated
too often the decisions are taken by
chin stroking bearded hipsters you voted
for Bernie Sanders and think Trump is
the devil banned people for breaking the
law not because they're not woke enough
well joining me now is host of podcast
on Kara Swisher Seth Dillon CEO visiting
website Babylon B who met Trump actually
this week to discuss all this uh I've
got my pack as well the broadcaster Alex
Phillips Lauren commentator Paula Roan
Adrian and talk to me International
editor Isabel ugly shot so a stellar
panel of frenzied social media uses on
my ad have all been gathered to debate
all this uh let me start with you Seth
Dillon because you're really one of the
reasons that Elon Musk ended up buying
Twitter if you believe his tweets
because he was incense that people like
you were getting effectively censored
and banned by the former Twitter regime
and that this was only ever skewed
towards conservatives
well yeah I don't think that we were the
sole reason that he did that I think he
was primarily concerned about restoring
free speech and we were one egregious
example of how just making jokes you
know making jokes that you're not
supposed to make was resulting in
suspensions where our speech was being
curbed so uh you know he saw that as
problematic and wanted to step in and do
something about it and I I think it's a
great thing that he did somebody needed
to as Bill Maher said Twitter needs a
new sheriff they weren't doing a very
good job deciding what's true and what's
right and what's hateful yeah well I can
really agree and it always seemed to be
skewed one way towards people on the
right so current Swisher I mean that was
my experience as somebody who sits you
know pretty much in the middle a lot to
consider myself I I was watching this
thinking well it is only actually people
on the right who were getting slung off
Twitter it's only people like Babylon
but it's only people like Donald Trump
it's never the hardcore left who
sometimes can be just as outrageous and
defensive
well you know the Babylon bee thing was
ridiculous I would agree that they
shouldn't have been kicked off I mean
you can think it's the joke was funny or
not but it was there was nothing wrong
with having satire and things like that
on there and I think it gets more
problematic when you have someone like
Donald Trump possibly uh promoting
violence and that's the problem here is
that they have these rules and they were
they were just they were never they were
random and that's the problem with it I
don't necessarily think there's any
beard stroking Bernie Sanders person I
think that's a Trope also but that they
were randomly
um put in place and there's actually
been some new reporting also that they
they were too scared to take things down
too of conservatives and I think that's
the problem is that these companies were
unaccountable to anyone as you noted
um have no ability to make rules that
they stick to and that's that's the
problem with Facebook too they sort of
did this two-year ban what's a two-year
ban what does that mean
um because they they didn't have the
guts to kick them off I guess or not or
I don't don't kick them off if you don't
think it's a real ban and so I think the
problem is these are make being made by
singular people uh even if it's Elon
Musk he had the same problem this week
with Nick Fuentes he brought him back on
and he kicked him right off
um
yeah Kanye West I think it's going to be
a problem forever because they make
these rules they don't enforce them and
then they change them and nothing makes
sense and that that to me is the real
problem is that you're putting people in
place that don't have any business
making decisions for the rest of society
including real societal harm uh
possibilities yeah I don't disagree with
that I mean Seth Dillon you were
actually with Donald Trump uh yesterday
I think um you were having dinner with
him what was his view about whether he
should come back onto social media
because obviously he's had the
invitation to come back to Twitter which
he hasn't taken yet because he has his
own truth social media platform but did
you get a feeling he is going to come
steaming back
I'm not sure I don't know that he's made
that decision yet
um but he shares the concern that a lot
of Americans can share that there's
politically motivated Viewpoint
discrimination happening on these
platforms he was a victim of it we've
been a victim of it you know it whether
it goes one way or not I don't think is
really the issue
um sure it's a problem if it's if it's
one-sided or the rules aren't being
applied fairly but this is the the
Public Square of the Modern Age where
people need to be able to have a voice
there's a recent case that just happened
you know you had this uh House Bill 20
was passed in Texas where they were
trying to make politically motivated
Viewpoint discrimination illegal and an
Obama appointed judge enjoined that law
and then the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals looked at it they said no listen
there is no hidden right to censor in
the First Amendment censorship isn't
speech so these platforms don't have a
constitutional right to be able to
censor you they need to let you speak
and express your viewpoints they
shouldn't be deciding what's true they
shouldn't be moderating jokes because
they think the jokes are hateful and
saying things like when Trump got kicked
off Twitter people don't know this but
try Trump got kicked off Twitter for
saying I won't be attending the
inauguration and he said my supporters
will have a voice long into the future
what rule does that supposedly violate
it's not unlawful speech it's not
inciting anyone it's not calling for
anything you have to read that into it
and that's the problem is you can you
should be able to express your opinions
say what you believe even if it's not
true you have a right to be wrong
Hillary Clinton said that his election
in 2016 was illegitimate she had every
right to say that if she wanted to say
that she's going to make that point is
it it was exactly the same thing about
that they all said that that election
was stolen from them there was no
difference
not accurate
you know look it was slightly different
but to me the generalized sort of
overview of it all it's not much
difference between one group of people
saying but it's different
let me say one thing first of all you're
saying it's a Public Square it's not a
Public Square it's a profit making
business they can do whatever they want
you can do whatever you want you don't
have any right to be on Twitter you
don't have any right to be on Facebook
and I think that's the problem is we've
become to think of it as that I think
the real problem is when the government
does intervene including in Texas which
is going to get over going to be an
overrule because of the First Amendment
they should also be able to put on what
they want and I think the problem is
everyone's decided they own these things
we did start the internet the U.S
taxpayer paid for the internet and
that's for sure but these businesses can
do whatever they want the real problem
it seems to me the most egregious
example I think of what was going on was
the New York Post expose day of Hunter
Biden agree and that laptop several
weeks before that election uh where we
don't know what would have happened if
if Twitter hadn't banned the New York
Post site completely and basically
airbrushed that expose which turned out
let me just say that was yeah but I
changed it really quickly they you and I
have talked about this they change it
really quickly they said they made a
mistake he said it in Congress
Dominion I didn't change it until after
the election action and the big
unanswerable question now is what impact
would it have had if the mainstream
media had not all convinced themselves
this was Russian propaganda and had
actually gone after that story as
aggressively as they should have done
three weeks before an election it could
have tilted things Trump's way so you
actually had a direct example of a
social media platform Banning a story
and a newspaper from publishing that
true story which could have influenced
the result of an election
and you have the same thing with Fox and
Dominion should they have been able to
broadcast those election things I mean I
think that's the problem is that these
sites have so much power over everyone
and yet they're private companies and so
what is the what is the solution in the
case of Babylon Bay it takes Elon Musk
to buy it and let them back on and
that's the solution unfortunately a
billionaire has to buy it
um I think the problem is is we've
gotten we have these private uh profit
making companies making decisions for
all of society and by the way they're
allowed to even if they make a mistake
even if they make the wrong call even if
they say they need to make a distinction
though we need to make a distinction
between how it is and how it should be
and like you just acknowledged these
private companies exercise a ton of
power the primary threat to speech used
to be the government but now because
people speak online the primary threat
to speech is these online forums that
are owned by private companies and the
question like justice Thomas is asking
is should SEC should a common carrier
Doctrine apply to them should we have
rules in place regulations in place
where uh discriminate nation is
prohibited I think a good argument can
be made the common carrier Doctrine
could and should apply to these private
companies even though they're privately
owned so that people are not
discriminated against unfairly and they
still have a voice let me ask you let me
ask you where do you think the line is
with freedom of speech nobody I don't
think believes it should be completely
unfulfilled in other words that anything
goes for example can you well Kanye West
for example when he literally is brought
back on Twitter and one of the first
things he does is post the Star of David
with a swastika inside it if you were
running Twitter even with your Zeal for
free speech which I share would you have
tolerated that
well I do think it's a place for
moderation I think that you get into
really tricky places when you try to
moderate people's opinions I think that
people have a right to opinions even
opinions that are wrong opinion that's a
deliberate attempt but you can I mean
that's not an opinion is it yes just
that's basically inciting
Nazi hatred against the Jewish people
through symbolism isn't it yeah and
these platforms should be able to
moderate content that they believe is
obscene and objectively offensive that
isn't Viewpoint related I think they
absolutely should be able to they should
be able to moderate unlawful speech I
think that they give people a lot of
tools for example if you say things that
upset me all the time if you're trolling
me or making fun of me and making me
feel bad I can block you I can mute you
I have that control and I can control
who I see and who I hear from Leave it
in people's hands what they see what
they consume let them reach their own
decisions stop trying to decide for them
what's true what they're allowed to joke
about what they're allowed to believe
the thought control and speech control
that these private companies are
exercising right now is having
detrimental effects in society
just want to ask you one question
because you were at this dinner with
with Trump and in the background of the
picture of one of the other people you
were with the libs of tick tock I think
they call themselves they mock liberal
people for doing silly things uh in the
background yeah there's a picture of
what looked like Nick Clegg who's the
spokesman for Facebook who you know well
over here was it Nick Clegg was he there
I'm not sure I wasn't aware of that and
I don't know who else was present I
gotta say it looks either it's Nick leg
or it's a dead ringer for Nick clay
which prompts all sorts of questions
what the hell was he doing there anyway
I'm gonna leave it there with you too
this was great thank you both very much
because you're both very tapped into all
this it is a complex thing I personally
am very glad Elon Musk is wrestling
through it because I think he comes from
a good place about it but we'll see he's
he's found out pretty quickly it's tough
it's tough in the jungle uh bakara and
so thank you both very much indeed and
Seth great to have you back on Twitter I
missed I've missed Babylon B you're
hilarious uh so good to see you buddy
thank you very much all right quick
reaction from from the pack um you'll
stay with us for the show so don't worry
you've got plenty of air time but
Isabella it's complex but would you have
let Trump back absolutely I think that
banning him for as long as he was banned
it was completely disproportionate you
gave brilliant examples in your intro
about the Iranian Ayatollah you know the
bile that comes in the nonsense that's
churned out by the Kremlin it is makes
no sense whatsoever to ban Trump in that
context and you know your interviewee
made really important points about no
one has to follow Trump I mean you can
just unfollow you don't have to read
this stuff and I think the thing that
concerns me and and they're right that
these are private businesses they it's
up to them but they mustn't masquerade
as Arbiters of the truth they mustn't
masquerade as independent you know
perhaps they should say what their
position is we are a left-leaning
whatever
um so likely you're not going to get a a
fair hearing if you disagree would you
have let Trump back on I would have
actually yeah and for I know this is
going to be a shock to you Isabel but
actually there's a lot we agree on here
a fair woman and that's big and the
reason why I would have let him back on
actually is because I want to be able to
see him and I want to be able to hear
him right and I want to be able to
challenge him and my concern is is that
if he doesn't have a platform where I
can do that at if he isn't accessible to
me if I can't hear him then he's going
to continue to say these things and I'm
going to be out well it's one of the
reasons actually Alex I for example
interviewed Alex Andrew Tate twice in
the last few months because I was made
aware by my sons all in my 20s that this
guy has an unbelievable following sort
of below the radar not on mainstream
media he'd be no platform everywhere and
I thought well this is actually really
odd situation and when I interviewed him
they both got gigantic viewer numbers I
mean off the charts it's a really good
example you've brought up there because
you know let's do an appraisal of what
social media has bought it is the most
pervasive and pernicious weapon of mass
destruction essentially against Society
that's been created in San Francisco
what does social media usher in it
bombards young people vulnerable people
with woke trends that see them mutilate
their own bodies it enables traffickers
to Usher tens of thousands of people as
human cargo across the channel it is
fundamentally changing the fabric of
society and it is penetrable are
manipulatable by foreign enemies
essentially the Genies out of the bottle
it's an unregulated Wild Wild West in
which life goes in parallel to regular
life and bad toxic things on the
internet seep down and tear Society I
know the problem I have is a former
newspaper editor we were highly
regulated in the newspaper game we're
highly regulated now in the British
television game by ofcom but there's no
regulation really that goes on with
these Tech Giants and in particular
we've had these stories of these young
girls who are getting sucked down rabbit
holes on Instagram taken to places that
fuel suicidal thoughts and so on with no
legal accountability or regulation at
the moment to stop these companies
letting their algorithms do this kind of
thing and that I think is almost one of
the biggest scandals of all about it
well we know about your own situation
don't we the terrifying situation where
you've had death threats and it's there
for everybody to see and everybody to
read and yet the police will come back
and tell you well I I had it myself I
mean somebody made a death threat
against me or my son's Instagram in
public clear specific death threat I
reported that the police someone gets
arrested five months later and a year
after that they come back and say we
can't do anything so he gets away with
it I mean literally unbelievable I'm
gonna leave it there for now I'm gonna
come back with you guys quick question
though should was Jesus non-binary
certainly not
Byron I don't know was Judas a woman
she couldn't ask a question about
Muhammad could you yeah
Jesus Christ Superstar which has gone
woke with a non-binary Act of playing
Jesus the woman playing Judas as the
world gone nuts I'll debate that with
Oscar nominated actor Tom Ponte and the
original Lyricist Tim Rice
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up we're in the group of global
obesity epidemic should we be kinder to
obese people like Austin Motors actor
Brendan Fraser is urging us to do or is
it time for some straight talking home
truth bad show me Alaska celebrity chef
who's lost 12 Stones on Carriage she'll
be on in a moment but first more than 50
years since it first sparked controversy
on stage Jesus Christ Superstar has been
resurrected and the 21st century plot
twist is gone gender neutral of course
Jesus is non-binary Judas will be played
by a woman and none of the Apostles are
men the production is required to keep
the original lyrics which means
non-binary Jesus will be referred to as
him rather than they or rather confuse
him and joining me now to discuss this
is the Tony award-winning actor Tom
Conte and so Tim Rice who of course
wrote the original Jesus Christ
Superstar featuring a red-blooded male
Jesus alongside Andrew Lloyd Webber well
welcome to both of you uh so Tim let me
start with you this is your your baby
this is your production
um are you happy that has gone all woke
yeah I'm I'm fine basically peers
because
if if if they sing the right words in
the right place to the right tune that's
really all that matters we've seen all
girl performances of Superstar before I
slightly resent you saying it's been
resurrected because it's never gone away
brag for a minute
um but but the first time I saw it with
an all-female cast was at St Mary's Khan
School in uh oh my gosh I think about
1989 or 19 and an all-girl cast and he
did it brilliantly but they stuck to the
words so after a few songs you you
forgot that Judas was actually being
sung by a woman or Jesus being sung by a
woman and you get into it and uh this
this show I gather doesn't change the
words and we said fine you can do it but
you mustn't start singing I don't know
how to love them right but this is okay
but this is where to me it becomes a bit
of a farce if you're going to have a
non-binary Jesus then you have to use
the correct preferred pronouns the whole
point of being non-binary is you don't
get called he or she you get called them
and they which I never understand
because there's only one person involved
but if you're the guy here saying this
is all fine but at the same time
assisting on the original lyrics what
you're really saying is something
because you're very clever is yeah you
can have our production but you stick to
our words which means actually Jesus is
not non-binary after all is he
well well that's their problem I mean
they can say Jesus is this is a
non-binary production but for far as I'm
concerned it is an all-female production
and they are not changing the show we've
had lots of different Productions of
Superstar I've seen it in Japan I've
seen it in you know um Mexico we're
seeing it Africa Kenya it's been done
everywhere and the cast hardly ever
Bears an accurate resemblance to the
original people what I did object to in
this particular case was the producer
some some Chapel I don't know what you
know whether he's a chap or not but
whatever he was he was saying that the
Christian Community
he was saying that the Christian
Community had never really embraced
Superstar but that's absolute cobblers
um the pope likes Superstar I'm not
saying that everybody in the Christian
Community likes it but it has definitely
made a positive impact I think that
wasn't Our intention
I love Superstar he's one of the
all-time great musicals all right Tom
Conte you've heard the witness for the
defense here who actually wrote the
words to this but I think you think I've
exposed a slight floor here which is if
you're going to bill it as non-binary
but then not use the non-binary pronouns
I I isn't this really just a PR scam
it's a little well I don't think it's a
br scam I don't know what it is actually
you know I was accused of of attacking
the shot I didn't ever mention
um the show on the on the world at one I
didn't mention Jesus Christ Superstar
um Helen LED was out and then you didn't
mentioned generally but Tim Rice is
actually more upset you didn't mention
the show
um this is you gave a pretty a pretty
animated interview too world at one but
what is your take about this generally I
mean it comes back to the debate for
example about James Bond right should
James Bond be a woman as some people
would like him to be should James Bond
go non-binary blah blah blah what do you
think the line should be with all these
calculations it was it's it's very
difficult I mean I you know I'm a
liberal person so I think people ought
to be able to do what they want to do
and this guy wants to do this production
I think there's he's entitled to do it I
don't want to go and see it because I
don't understand why I don't see the
point in in doing it I don't see the
point in casting a woman to play you
know Mark Anthony because then you begin
to wonder was is he having an affair
with Caesar and that's right is that why
he's so upset when she was murdered you
know it opens all sorts of doors but
also if you write if you write roles for
women then they're going to be different
to the way you would write a role for a
man I don't think you could just change
gender you'd have to basically go back
and rewrite the whole script that's
right because men and women are
psychologically different the the
reality different ways to different
situations you you can't just change he
to she but but I just I wish I think Tim
is jumping at the bit to get in here Tim
what are you hearing this that's
wounding you up no I I was I was I was
only going to say that there have been
plenty of all female versions of Hamlet
or or fellow and this at the other and
as long as the basic work is the same I
don't really mind what people do as long
as I mean I'm delighted that the the
Superstar and other stuff I've done over
the years can be done in lots of
different ways but you can't change
what's there if you don't like the piece
don't do it but if you do like it then
I'm delighted it's done in different
ways but this this is obviously not the
way forward for something like James
Bond I believe James Bond was written
for a bloke I mean the character has to
be a man you can do lots of wonderful
movies and plays with with super Dynamic
female agents or non-binary agents or
whatever the expression is I don't
really understand what non-binary is
myself but but the basic work is
Paramount
I can pick you up on that so that's very
interesting so you think James Bond
couldn't be non-binary or female but
you're happy for Jesus Christ well I
think it would be non-binary or female I
wish well I go hang on surely the two of
them are inextricably linked to the fact
they're men
well yes and no I mean there's no reason
on Earth why
there's no reason on Earth I suppose why
James Bond couldn't be female but he
should still be or it or God I'm getting
confused I'm getting into a terrible
right now
does he have girlfriends
James Bond is something becomes a woman
what happens to all those dinghy scenes
at the end
well I don't know I mean it's not my
problem I would not get involved with
changing James Bond to that extent but
but super but I mean we had a case in in
New Zealand of all places with Joseph
which you would have thought nobody
would be mad enough to change Joseph but
they wanted to change the line children
of Israel are never alone to Children of
kindness are never alone which was
meaningless and frankly sentimental
dribble and we weren't sure why and we
said sorry you can do the show we're
delighted you're doing it but you you
have to stick to the words that were
written even if you don't like them and
they said well in that case we won't do
the show and we said fine and in the end
as it happened in that case they backed
down but I think the work itself should
not be altered I mean James Bond is a
slightly different case because there
was no actual standard James Bond plot
right my concern about this gender issue
generally is take the Brit Awards which
have just announced last year they're
going to go gender neutral with your
walls right and I warned when this
happened uh Tom Conte that when it
happened
that what would be the inevitable result
was that the next batch of nominations
probably all be met and then everyone
must scream how ridiculous it was that's
exactly what happened so all five
nominations for the best artists turned
out to be male this year and all the
women who've been excluded quite rightly
go was this ridiculous
um I don't see any problems celebrating
women femininity female roles female
singers I don't want a gender-neutral
Oscars do you no absolutely not and you
deny someone an Oscar or a bafta
whatever it is if you say no we're only
going to give best actor and of course
by saying actor we also include the word
actress
um but then
one person doesn't get you know it
should be two people getting an award
but now only one person is getting an
award so who does that benefit well it
doesn't benefit women no certainly also
I mean I I know Dame Jones Colin's very
well and she's she insists on calling
herself an actress she doesn't record an
actor she thinks men are called actors
yeah but this is all part of the sort of
the gender neutral neutralizing of
language generally which I think is very
problematic no I I agree I don't know
why I don't know why this is happening
it's it's bewildering to people you know
people just say well I'm a stupid old
white man you know which is a kind of
racist comment but they were yeah um but
I I don't understand why it's happening
I don't see the point of any of it
really Tim Rice you've actually I think
hosted the Brits right what do you think
of the Brits going gender neutral do you
agree with gender neutral award shows
well
not really well I mean quite a few of
the awards as it happened are General
neutral um gender neutral um I mean Best
Director best whatever but um I think
the Brits have slightly shot themselves
in the foot I did present the Brits back
in the Stone Age when no one really took
myself down but I I mean once once you
get into the um this this whole gender
thing I mean it's ludicrously
complicated I mean both Tom and I are
slightly about as to what to say I can
just go back to the same thing saying
the work is Paramount and if if you want
to do the piece do it but don't try and
rewrite it well to me yeah you are
rewriting it aren't you if you've
shuddenly having all women or all men
playing women or the other you are
completely changing well in a way you're
not I mean I mean I mean I mean the the
the Indigo Girls
um an American
um female or female band did a rather
nice album of Superstar with with only
women's singing all the parts and they
stuck to the actual songs they got the
words right they've got the tunes right
they made a great album I didn't mind
that at all I thought that was nice that
was a interesting way but but if if they
changed it to I don't know how to love
her or you know um so you are the lady
Christ a great lady Christ or something
that that would have been wrong I just I
thought you're heading into it but once
he starts trying to pretend it's
non-binary but the lyrics stay the same
as if it's a man then the non-binary
thing becomes to me a complete fast
because the whole point of being
non-binary I would agree they are them
where is this going on this production
in Scotland yes in Edinburgh in
Edinburgh yeah oh they're very confused
well we know listen we know what's
happened in Scotland I mean on a serious
point where this gender stuff takes you
is it takes you right down this rabbit
war and we get in Scotland with this
trans rapist who ends up raping two
women as a man transitions before his
trial and ends up being sent to a
woman's prison until today when is now
being taken off she or they or them
whatever he or they want to call
themselves is a rapist I don't care
about respecting his pronouns but he's
now been put back into a into a male
prison and I would say quite rightly but
this is the problem when gender gets
that confused people will exploit it
anyway no so this whole thing in
Scotland of of letting um youngsters of
16 decide what they're going to be I
mean the synapses in the brain are not
fully connected they're not allowed to
buy a drink legally in Scotland until
they're 18. but the brains aren't fully
formed at 16. that's the huge danger
yeah yeah Tom Johnson Tim Rice what a
great debate with two legends Legends I
don't use that word Loosely Legends of
stage and Screen what a pleasure to have
you both good luck and both I I presume
just find that you're both identifying
as male this evening
well I'm trying hard I'm I'm a bloke I
think I'm like I'm fairly inefficient so
all three of us
yeah right uh great to see you we've got
to leave it there thank you very much
indeed chats much much well coming up
next actor Brendan Fraser plays an obese
recluse in his new film and says we need
to stop the bias against fat people but
is he right do fat people actually need
to be fat shamed into losing weight we
talked to a man who lost 12 stone the
Superstar Chef Tom Carriage next
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back Brendan Fraser's portrayal
of a morbidly obese recluse in the film
The Whale is under an Oscar nomination
he's spoken out about society's
treatment of overweight people according
to the need to stop the bias against
those with obesity but an age where the
world is in the grip of an obesity
epidemic not least which in this country
is this whole notion of body positivity
making the problem worse I'm joined Now
by Great British menu star Tom Carriage
who famously lost 12 stone and looking
in magnificent show you work out every
day you would just tell him I do I try
to work out every day in different
things so when I first lost a load of
weight it was through cardiovascular
stuff so I swam so I used to swim mile
every day how big were you at your beach
oh it's over 30 Stone 30 Stone yeah yeah
in that moment what was the trigger for
you actually saying I've really got to
do something about this age so there's a
point where you get to so I was
approaching my 40th birthday and I think
that's always a point of reflect action
isn't it I think when you get to 40 I
mean I know it's not that long ago a few
peers but you get to that point where
you just think where what have I
achieved what have I come to and where
am I going so I think I think there's a
point 40 if is is always a real kind of
a testing point for many people for me
it was okay what have I achieved what am
I doing career-wise it was all going
great the restaurants were fantastic the
pub was great the recognition was good
we were doing stuff on the Telly so
there was no there wasn't a health scare
which I'm sure there would have been at
some point there wasn't there was there
was no conversation of yours or family
or viewers whatever it may be were
people making comments to you that made
you think you know what about your
weight about your size whether people
was that part of it as well no no no
none of it it was all self-conscious so
the thing about anything that you have
to do whether it's losing weight whether
it's an issue with addiction whether
it's giving up smoking whether it's
alcohol whether it's gambling whatever
it is whatever it's part of your life
none of us are stupid we all know it's
bad for you if you eat loads of Mars
Bars every day you know you're going to
be in a bad space if you're drinking
energy it's about self-responsibility so
a lot of it comes to you know what am I
going to do to change the bad habit my
issue with the debate is it obesity
rates we know are just going through the
roof all around Europe actually but
particularly in this country where it's
shocking uh and America
um and I see people for example I
remember a while ago a a model in
America she was a plus-sized model
called Tess holiday she appeared on the
cover of Cosmopolitan magazine here she
was over 300 pounds and about five foot
tall and there wasn't a single word in
the whole piece which did anything other
than celebrate her supposed body
positivity I felt that was incredibly
harmful in terms of making people think
this is
actually a positive thing that's morbid
obesity that's going to kill someone so
then the positivity that's a mindset yes
okay I think if you are if you're
morbidly obese I mean the word morbid in
front of it is frightening and it's
something that you have to reflect on on
yourself but then at the same point but
my foot does fat shaming if you you know
when I when I put on a bit too much
Timber I can absolutely rely on one of
my sons they're all pretty fit or my
brothers who are not as fit actually but
like to dig it out
um what the first thing they'll do is is
say oh you put some Timber on right and
that will always make me go back to the
gym yeah in other words I believe that a
bit of fat shaming goes quite a long way
in making you think actually really okay
I better do something about it well not
all of us are in the same fortunate
position as you me and you where we can
go to a gym we have a gym that we can go
to that we remember running yeah but but
we all know that if if it's not
something that you actually enjoy doing
it's not something that you're going to
continue to do so the exercises that you
need to do the way that you can do it is
by finding something that you enjoy
doing if you if you do something shaming
is wrong
um yeah I think a lot of it's about
education a lot of it comes down to
poverty and if you think of the most the
majority of places where you'll find
that most people are morbidly obese are
places where they come from economically
challenged areas where the foods that
they can afford have done that process
right so a lot of it will come down to
food poverty so it's not necessarily
about eating too much it's about eating
the wrong foods and the problem with
those wrong foods are processed foods
that are saturated fat high in sugars
they lead to what you think is those
processed carbohydrates fill you up but
they don't last very long so you eat
more and you get into this very a
vicious circle and that it's not about
fresh vegetables it's not about and
that's also a food education point if
you save up alcohol completely I did
yeah I stopped drinking how big a factor
do you think in your dramatic weight
loss was the just killing the booze oh
massive hello so I have an issue with
alcohol so my I that first and foremost
that was a big part of giving up and
losing weight was an issue with alcohol
but also even if you're a mild Drinker
or someone who just drinks at a weekend
alcohol changes your mindset so it does
lead you to go and I'll have cheese on
total or go for that Curry or I'll have
that Kebab no question so it's not just
about the Lost calories or the weight
that you could put on from alcohol and
the sugars that are in it it's actually
from the mindset that changes and that's
see I'm on a bit of a health kick at the
moment so I've had barely any alcohol in
five weeks eating very healthily going
to the gym two or three times a week
Peloton the other days right and I'm
getting quite fit again as I've done
productively but there's always a moment
when I'm going to hit that wall when I
you just slightly lose that Steely
self-discipation Street you came through
that yeah and most people don't what
especially in July January and so on
what's your advice to people to break in
through the wall there's a mindset and
but it's very very different when both
me and you now are in that point of
middle age where you're struggling every
day and you're trying to find that
balance between everything where if
you're morbidly obese with the point
where I was well over 30 Stone you're
then at point that your life is so
unbalanced it's completely out of
control that one thing is you have to
unbalance it completely the other way so
you have to remove whether it's
carbohydrates or sugars or lower
calories and alcohol and you have to it
becomes unbalanced the other way if you
have a relatively balanced diet which
sounds like you have now when you go up
and down and you're you're kind of in
control of it like everybody else and
that's okay what you do is okay you know
but it is that point where you do find
yourself that you are overweight you
need to it is a structured mindset and
most of it does come down to finding
food but I would say the most
motivational thing in my life over the
years about losing weight was actually
reading Ali Ross's TV column in the sum
where this pasty face little
from Aberdeen would regularly torment me
for being fat now I thought he was right
so it made me get fit so I think there's
an example where being fat shamed
actually can help it just cuts through
all the crap does that works for you you
are too fat that works for you but
there's many people you don't know their
situations you don't know where they're
at you don't know why their mindset is
like that and the only way that you're
ever going to lose weight or you're only
going to do that is if you can do it you
have to do it yourself and somebody's
telling you you already know you're fat
you I mean you have a shower every day
or a bath and you get out and you see
yourself in a mirror right you know you
know you're overweight it's actually
going and currently I'm seeing a lean
mean fighting machine exactly that
six-pack is shine and free thank you it
is going to be that point where you have
to make that decision and it can only
come down it doesn't matter how many
people take in fact that could probably
make it worse if you have some form of
insecurity and somebody's telling you
you know you come for eat if you're
comforting anyway and then you're
constantly getting told that it can only
lead to work so I'm gonna leave it there
I want to talk to you again another time
about Pub because I was brought up in a
pub yeah and I share your passion for
pubs and as a war on pubs as we know a
lot of them going under and so we'll do
another debate on that another time but
it's great to talk to you about this
it's a really big issue a lot of people
out there at the moment doing this dry
January to be January which I'd rather
suit myself than do uh and you're a
prime example of how you can do it
congratulations thank you young man
cheers Chief well coming up Scotland
finally sees sense a transgender rapist
will be moved out of a woman's only
prison
how did it ever come to that in the
first place that's next with the pack
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we'll have to wave of the flag for
transgender rights Scotland's first
Minister was forced into an embarrassing
climb down Isla Bryson or Adam as she
used to be known and raped two women as
Adam before changing gender at trial was
awaiting sentencing in a women's prison
in Scotland after a huge outcry she he
they will now be moved to a jail with
male inmates returning is my pay so
Paula complex issue but this goes right
to the heart of me of what I've always
warned about this the moment you allow
Limitless gender identity you're going
to get people trying it out this this
guy's ex-wife came out here today he's
never had an inkling it'll mentioned a
word of any of this until he got done
for two rapes Riders was going to prison
for a horrific time in a Men's prison
and put his hand up transitioned and
then goes into a female prison with
women he can attack and let's not be
surprised here of a criminal all not
telling the truth peers I accept that it
happens of course it does and people you
will always find somebody who is going
to try and test the citizen to its
limits I get that but in terms of
equating this Horror Story with the
transgender debate that worries me
because they're two separate things and
do you still think it's perfectly okay
for six foot three inch former male
swimmers to now be smashing women's
records in swimming pools in America for
example so what I think is appropriate
is that okay so what I think is
appropriate is ministers
I think is okay is that the ioc who have
done the research who have spoken to the
scientists who have spoken to the other
athletes and who have decided that from
I think it was 2004 that transgender
athletes could compete yeah they're the
ones who are making the decisions this
to me this whole gender thing is getting
hijacked by very aggressive Lobby
activists from the trans side and people
are simply too terrified actually to put
their head over the parapet and call
foul when it creates a new unfairness
well this is the thing it's actually not
a complex debate is it we have a
position we had positions in plate that
place that if people had gender
dysphoria they had counseling they had
Medical Treatments they went for surgery
if that is what was suitable for them
and they were part of the community I
don't think that there was you know a
huge airport I didn't know about a huge
airport about trans people until very
recently most trans people I know are
very upset about all this right what's
being present
of them as trans people they don't agree
with the new unfairness that has been
created in all these different areas and
that seems to me you know I want to take
care of trans people who just want to
have get on with their lives and have
fairness and equality that's what my
concern is creating a new unfairness and
eroding women's rights in the process is
not the answer well I I agree with Alex
I think this is actually really simple
and I think there's a very simple way of
approaching it which is that if you
commit a crime as a man particularly if
it's a violent sexual offense as a man
that only a man can perpetrate in that
way then you should be tried and charged
and sentenced as a man it doesn't matter
if you you fiddle around with your sex
afterwards you're going to be punished
as you were for the crime that you
carried out and I just can't see why you
need to complicate that anything okay
now I want a little moment silence here
of of thought and prayers for the
Guardian newspaper the chief woke
publication in the world who have just
been accused of institutional racism uh
in a comic alternative events producers
working for the guardian on a podcast
about the guardian have discovered links
between his founder John Edward Taylor
and slavery good a leaked emails are the
key issue is a lack of any serious
desire from the guardian to face and
interrogate its own historic role I
think we can all surely share our dish
dismay that these wokies have been
caught with their racist trials isn't it
gorgeous to watch the left-wing
self-cannibalizing you know the battle
of the rice the battle
this is always what's going to happen I
think we just sit back and go go
over it well you'll be pleased to hear I
read lots of different Publications
um I have done yeah I have done I've
read the sun I've read the times I've
read the unit post I've read the variety
I've read you name it what is the point
about this my point about this this
racism charge about when you go back in
history over every institution I just
think it's a waste of people's time and
energy and money what are we trying to
prove that the guardian which does
Endless let's be clear they do a lot of
very good work about racism and now
they're accused of being a bunch of
races because the founder whenever it
was 200 years ago had links to slavery
and now it's all been abolished many
many decades ago I don't get the point
of it and I don't either I have to say I
was confused by the story and where
where they would go in with this because
I'd have to say that I think many people
would struggle to go back 200 years and
not find something I love to think that
the guardian would learn a lesson about
this and and what lesson would that be
well not dig back into your history
everybody else not be endlessly
hypocritical I mean just absolutely
ridiculous it's the kind of story The
Guardian would love to expose about
somebody else you know we've had the
enlightened era we've had the
Renaissance it seems to me we now live
in an era of persecution and the
everything about Society
it is it is it's McCarthy I actually the
woke fascists are trying to behave like
McCarthy and we're going to stand up to
them and I will stand on some no such
thing as a woke fascist yes there is
Paula there's no such thing you can have
a culture
keep it unsensitive good night
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign